[Music]
every warrior
has the beginning i'm on a new level
for 600 years our ninja had brought
peace
the journey from here
is yours to decide
but that is just the beginning i'm on a
new level
in the gi joe comics snake eyes is one
of those characters that's had kind of a
mysterious past
it was famously known as the silent
ninja this
is morning night larry hammer really
blossomed the character
within an issue called the silent
interlude which had
no words just pictures when i did the
comic
i made it character-centric i came up
with the backstory of storm shadow
takes snake eyes into the clan larry
hama created the modern day version of
what we know gi joe to be
we try to find a balance between what is
pre-existing gi joe
law but also finding a way of updating
it giving people more
that opened up a world of opportunity
let's do the origin story before he's
lost his voice
let's go shooting in japan
was super important for driving a story
when you go to japan there's some energy
that you pick up from actually being
there
i'm super excited for people to see what
we're building
this is literally a stepping stone into
the gi joe universe
[Music]
you